alors aujourd'hui on se parle de l'iPad
pro 2022 on se parle de l'iPad pro
modèle 12,9 pouces il y a deux modèles
d'iPad pro qui existe nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est le plus gros le plus
important le plus impressionnant pour
qu'on peut même venir dire ça alors moi
je vous montre la version que j'ai j'ai
bien un iPad pro 12,9 pouces version 1
To on se parle bien ici de la 6e
génération d'iPod pro il faut le savoir
et moi j'ai une version Wi-Fi plus
cellular ça veut dire qu'en fait je peux
avoir de la 5G dès lors que je mets une
ici ou une carte SIM là dedans donc ça
voilà quand ma machine cette machine
elle est donc située ici ici là regardez
juste à l'intérieur alors je l'ai mise
dans le Magic keboard que j'utilise
parce que je trouve ça très pratique et
ça transforme totalement votre iPad ça
transforme en un ordinateur sans être
réellement un ordinateur donc la
question aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que ça
taille pas de 2022 c'est pas de 12,9
pouces l'iPad intéressant quelle est la
différence par rapport au modèle de 2021
qui est sorti il y a quelques 18 mois je
pense un truc comme ça est-ce qu'il faut
aller dessus quels sont les différences
est-ce qu'il vaut le coup quel est son
tarif fatalement il est plus cher on
regarde tout ça vous êtes prêt allez on
y va
[Musique]
la première chose à venir voir c'est ça
iPad il a exactement le même look que
l'iPad pro l'année dernière exactement
c'est le même format c'est la même chose
c'est le même look and feel vous le
prenez dans la main c'est la même chose
exactement que ce soit à l'avant ou à
l'arrière au niveau des bordures rien
n'a changé au niveau de l'arrière rien
n'a changé on a exactement les mêmes
modules photos à savoir un grand angle
de 12 mégapixels que bref un point 8 un
ultra grand-angle de 10 mégapixels que
vive 2.4 on a une caméra leader c'est
exactement la même chose et à l'avant
vous avez une caméra de selfie caméra
true dance qui est située juste
là-dedans dans le module de 12
mégapixels que également AF 1.8 cette
caméra trouble ça ne vous servira à
venir déverrouiller votre iPad avec
votre visage c'est ce qu'on appelle face
ID c'est pas tout nouveau encoller face
ID hop là je me mets en face tac il est
verrouille vous êtes là vous êtes bien
c'est tranquille ça c'est chouette on
connaît alors il y a un truc bon déjà
qui me fait pas un peu râler mais que je
viens noter première chose c'est la
couleur ici vous avez soit du gris
sidéral soit de l'argent sur les
couleurs très classiques des iPad pro et
sur le modèle professionnel on garde le
côté très sobre tandis que sur l'iPad 10
que je vous ai présenté l'autre jour
d'ailleurs allez voir ma vidéo si c'est
pas déjà fait et bien on se permet un
peu plus de fantaisie avec différentes
couleurs donc les iPad 10 on les iPad
familiaux alors il y a l'iPad air entre
et l'iPad pro on reste dans le
professionnel on reste en déteint très
standard et ça ne bouge pas ok ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point est
plus intéressant que ça je viens de vous
le montrer votre caméra elle se situe
juste ici juste en haut et ce qui est
super intéressant c'est que lorsque vous
prenez votre Magic keyboard pour venir
transformer votre iPad dans l'ordinateur
et bien vous l'avez sur un autre format
vous n'êtes pas en format portrait vous
passez en format paysage vous venez le
mettre là-dedans vous l'avez comme ça
vous le posez et vous le positionnez là
ça veut dire que lorsque vous êtes par
exemple en train de collaborer d'un
point de vue professionnel vous avez
votre iPad comme ça face à vous ok
jusque là on sait sauf que et c'est là
que c'est super intéressant votre webcam
elle est juste ici avec Center state ça
je vais vous montrer c'est quelque chose
qui est pas nouveau qu'on connaissait
qui est vraiment génial mais Apple vient
un peu contredire avec ce qu'ils ont
fait avec elle iPad 10 c'est-à-dire que
sur l'iPad 10 ils ont mis leur caméra
ici elle est juste là et ça c'est
vachement bien pourquoi parce que ce que
c'est dit lorsque vous venez faire un
col et bien en fait ce que vous voulez
c'est être vu directement au centre ici
et pas être vu sur le côté alors ça
c'est très surprenant parce que une fois
de plus ça on le voit directement sur
cet iPad là sur l'iPad 10 qui coûte déjà
un peu cher mais c'est l'iPad pour tout
le monde l'iPad familial ce n'est pas un
iPad professionnel tandis que lorsque
vous êtes sur l'iPad pro et bien là vous
voyez vous positionnez comme ça et vous
êtes de côté parce que votre webcam elle
est située sur le côté et là du coup
c'est beaucoup moins beau voyez je suis
en train de parler je suis comme ça donc
il y a une vraie différence et il y a un
vrai parti pris qui est très très
différent et que je trouve pour le coup
pas bon et je trouve ça dommage parce
que ce cas montrer Apple avec l'iPad 10
on aurait dû être réfléchi et intégré
dans l'iPad pro à moins que et bien ils
aient voulu économiser un petit peu sur
les coups qu'ils avaient déjà je vais
dire tout le châssis toute la
fabrication qui était faite comme ça et
qu'ils n'ont pas voulu réagencer avec
des grandes guillemets en tout cas
retravailler le design intérieur de leur
iPad donc je trouve ça très bien au
niveau de l'iPad 10 se trouve ça moins
bon au niveau de l'iPad pro parce que ce
que j'ai vu sur l'iPad 10 me plaît
beaucoup mieux et je trouve ça assez
dommage alors ça va pas changer la face
du monde vous avez toujours
stage ici qui est très bien et qui est
très cool alors c'est une
torse c'est dur à dire si vous savez pas
ce que c'est et bien c'est le fait que
votre iPad va venir vous suivre vous
voyez si je le mets comme ça je me
déplace sur le côté il me reconnaît ils
viennent suivre donc ça c'est quand même
vachement mal donc ça y est hop là vous
le prenez là il est beaucoup plus large
vous appuyez sur center stage ici il
resserre et ici votre visage donc bon
l'idée elle est plutôt marrante sauf que
vous êtes quand même toujours filmé de
côté et ça voilà c'est comme ça alors
une fois qu'on a regardé ce petit côté
là et qu'on a arrêté de râler on va
arrêter de râler monsieur heureux hein
n'est-ce pas et bien on a un super écran
l'écran est toujours d'excellente
qualité alors il y a une différence il
faut le savoir entre l'iPad 11 pouces et
l'iPad 12,9 pouces c'est que sur l'iPad
12,9 pouces vous avez la technologie
mini LED que vous n'avez pas de l'autre
côté dans les deux cas c'est une dalle
IPS c'est du LCD sauf qu'ici on est
effectivement sur du mini lait donc ça
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux le truc
qui est intéressant ici c'est que vous
avez un taux de contraste qui va être
beaucoup plus élevé sur le mini laine
vous avez une superbe dalle très jolie
pas très réfléchissante je trouve ça
plutôt bien donc elle est quand même
assez anti-reflet vu ce que je vais lui
mettre voyez avec la lumière au-dessus
et bien très honnêtement ça pourrait
être dire donc je trouve que ça marche
vraiment bien ça c'est très cool très
bien calibré on a le True tonne vous
avez le promotion vous avez le promotion
c'est le taux de rafraîchissement
variable qui ici va de 24 Hertz jusqu'à
120 Hertz jusqu'à 120 Hertz lorsque vous
avez des besoins sur des applications ou
sur du gaming parce que si vous avez
beaucoup de performances mais je vous en
parle aussi dans quelques instants un
écran qui est aussi très lumineux on a
minute on peut monter jusqu'à un pic de
1600 nits qui est quand même énorme ce
qui vous permet de l'emmener en
extérieur et de pouvoir voir ce qui se
passe sans aucun problème donc pour tout
ce qui va être usage professionnel
nomade où on va se balader on est dehors
il fait jour il y a du soleil ça
fonctionne pas de souci moi cet iPad je
l'utilise beaucoup et c'est un peu donné
du comme on dit du du caviar au cochon
je vous fais l'expression j'utilise
beaucoup pour le divertissement pour me
regarder des films des séries le soir
bah je m'en priverais pas c'est un super
bypad la qualité elle est dingue donc
c'est ce que je fais c'est à dire que je
le prends je le mets avec le Magic
keboard je le pose sur le lit parce que
je suis une grosse bouse le soir chez
moi et oui pas tellement donc je le pose
comme ça je peux l'orienter comme je
veux ça c'est le Magic qui bord qui est
vraiment génial pour ça et j'ai une
superbe qualité donc je doute que un
iPad qui coûte quand même 1500 balles
quasiment 1500 balles voir presque 3000
balles pour la plus grosse config mais
on va regarder ça dans quelques instants
et bien on peut l'utiliser pour du
divertissement dans quelle qualité est
vraiment super vous avez quatre que vous
regardiez du contenu comme ça à
l'horizontale ou que vous le switchez à
la verticale en mode portrait ça
fonctionne très bien donc soit du
portrait du paysage on a un truc qui est
très très bien c'est pareil pour les
appels pour les conversations lorsque
vous allez appeler des amis pour de la
conférence vous avez 5 micros qui vont
servir pour capter votre voix pour
capter les sons extérieurs pour venir
les Annuler pour optimiser tout ça donc
pour tout ce qui va être viré usage pro
sur la conversation même familiale ça
marche très bien pour du divertissement
c'est très bien pour le côté traitement
de texte avec le Magic keyboard c'est
aussi très très très bien et surtout le
truc qui est énorme et qui vachement
intéressant cette année c'est qu'ils ont
mis la puce m2 alors on avait la
dernière la puce M1 ça c'était déjà une
très très grosse force sur cet iPad avec
beaucoup de performances mais avec la m2
ça va beaucoup plus loin vous avez 8
cœurs au niveau du CPU vous avez 10
cœurs au niveau du GPU et c'est ce que
au niveau du neurale un jeune autant
vous dire vous avez une combinaison qui
marche très très bien alors on va pas
rentrer dans le détail quatre coeurs et
quatre coeurs enfin bref on s'en fout un
peu ce qu'il faut vraiment venir retenir
ici c'est que vous avez une bête de
puissance énormément de performance
voire trop de performances très
honnêtement je ne sais pas ce que vous
allez faire de toute cette performance
là on pense à un iPad pro pro de par les
usages de par la qualité on est sur ce
qu'Apple fait le mieux aujourd'hui sur
un iPad on est aussi sur le tarif le
plus élevé extrêmement cher ça dépend
une fois de plus de la configuration et
je vous parle des prix dans quelques
instants c'est du premium de l'ultra
premium ça coûte très cher il y a très
mal finition de très belles technologies
donc bon voilà vous le payer et vous
payez aussi la marque donc ça ça se
comprend parfaitement bien maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire vous
réellement de toute cette performances
dites le moi dans les commentaires
dites-le-moi moi l'iPad pro je l'ai déjà
j'utilise je fais ci je fais ça alors ça
vous me fassiez de la 3D vous passez des
trucs qui manque beaucoup de ressources
ou du multitâche je pense que la plupart
des personnes n'arriveront pas aux
limites de l'iPad pro après c'est aussi
le but Apple se dit pas tiens on va
créer une machine pour que les gens
arrivent rapidement limite et qu'ils
disent ah tiens je peux pas aller plus
loin c'est la merde non le but c'est que
vous l'atignez jamais les limites et
avec la puce m2 à l'intérieur vous êtes
vraiment peinard alors une petite
différence aussi au niveau de la
configuration qui est intéressante c'est
à dire que ça taille pas de au niveau du
stockage vous avez crochez-vous soit 128
soit 256 soit 512 soit un Téra soit deux
terrains de stockage donc vous avez
vraiment un éventail qui est énorme
alors une fois de plus il faut réfléchir
à ses usages est-ce que vous vous en
avez besoin beaucoup de stockage dans le
Cloud auquel cas ça sert à rien de
prendre le 2 Tera est-ce que à contrario
vous avez des fichiers lourds et vous
avez besoin de les stocker ici à
l'intérieur auquel cas le 2 terrasse est
peut-être franchement pas mal même si ça
coûte un petit peu cher au moins vous
serez peinard ou alors est-ce qu'un
disque dur externe vous pouvez me dire
branché ici en usb-c en thunderbol ça
pourrait venir vous convenir c'est aussi
la question en même temps vous pouvez
venir brancher un petit hub pour avoir
différents accessoires ça ça s'est très
bien il y en a donc ça c'est très cool
vous voyez il faut réfléchir à tout ça
et je voulais en venir là c'est à dire
que sur la version 128 jusqu'à 512 vous
avez 8 Go de RAM mais sur la version 1
To edotera vous doublez vous montez à 16
giga de ram donc si vous achetez un iPad
pro hop là Siri je t'ai rien demandé un
iPad pro avec intérêt voire deux
terrains vous avez beaucoup de stockage
vous avez la puce m2 et vous avez 16 Go
de RAM autant dire que ça va tartiner
une fois de plus va dépendre de vous et
de vos usages donc parlez-moi de vos
usages dites moi ce que vous en faites
en bas dans les commentaires je suis
très curieux à mon avis je pense que la
plupart des personnes qui achètent ça
seront plaisir mais ils vont pas
réellement pousser vraiment dans les
limites d'ailleurs moi c'est pas mon cas
je vais pas le pousser à fond j'en ai
pas le besoin autre truc à connaître ici
c'est que au niveau de l'autonomie on
est sur ce qu'on avait l'année dernière
on va pas quantifier l'autonomie d'un
iPad comme l'utilisation d'un smartphone
parce qu'on va pas être sur un usage
bout à vous en tout cas moi j'utilise
pas de bout à bout donc mon iPad je vais
le recharger tous les trois quatre jours
je viens le brancher alors ça va
dépendre de l'endroit où je me mets où
je suis posé ce que je recherche souvent
quand je suis dans mon lit le soir je
vais soit le recharger directement là
sur l'iPad ça va aller un peu plus vite
sinon je vais des fois le recharger ici
là vous voyez ça va aller un tout petit
peu moins vite mais ça reste quand même
correct toute façon votre iPad comme je
vous le dis vous avez pas besoin de le
recharger et de l'avoir pour repartir
pour 10h en 40 minutes de recharge donc
ça va être un peu plus long on va
prendre le temps d'autant plus que vous
avez un bloc de charge qui est inclus à
l'intérieur mais c'est du 20 watts donc
on n'a pas l'aspect Apple donne pas les
specs des batteries ici mais si on est
sur un petit 10000 milliards ça me
paraîtrait pas déconnant donc vous
faites le calcul milliards de la
recharge 20 watts voilà faut prendre
votre mal en patience faut pas trop être
pressé alors après l'autre point fort
ici d'un iPad quel qu'il soit c'est iPad
OS vous êtes sur iPad OS 16 qui marche
merveilleusement bien avec plein de
possibilités j'ai pas vous le détailler
aujourd'hui si c'est pas le sujet mais
si vous êtes déjà coutumier de iOS ou de
Mac OS iPad OS si vous ne connaissez pas
ça va pas vous surprendre ça marche très
bien l'expérience autre point qui est
intéressant aussi nouveauté par rapport
à l'année dernière vous avez du
Bluetooth 5.3 alors qu'avant vous aviez
du Bluetooth 5.1 alors on va dire ok ça
me posant 5.3 je m'en fous un peu galéré
de moi la différence alors il y a quand
même quelques petites différences qui
sont intéressantes et qui une fois de
plus sur un produit hyper haut de gamme
on se doit d'avoir une dernière
technologie ici le Bluetooth 5.3 vient
moins consommer comme Bluetooth 5.1 vous
aurez moins d'interférences et vous
aurez une meilleure qualité audio voilà
un peu l'idée globale donc vous êtes au
top de ce qu'on peut retrouver
aujourd'hui sur une machine comme ça
alors puisqu'on parle de technologie moi
il y a un truc que je trouve intéressant
et qui la ferraille avec les iPhone
c'est à dire que sur l'iPhone 14 pro 14
pro max on n'a pas de wifi si ce et je
me suis dit mais c'est pas possible que
Apple sur leur dernière mouture d'iPhone
n'aille pas le plus loin possible avec
du wifi 6e alors ils l'ont fait sur
l'iPad on a du wifi 6e qui est la
dernière norme de wifi alors vous êtes
déjà en wifi 6 ça va très bien mais
quand on met plus de 1000 balles 1200
1300400 balles voire plus il affinité
sur un iPhone on voudrait du wifi 6 il y
en a pas ici il y en a donc ça c'est
très très bien donc on est vraiment sur
les dernières techno on peut l'avoir en
version cellulaire je vous dis avec de
la 5G également si vous avez besoin de
vous connecter partout sans devoir faire
un partage de connexion qui viendra
taper dans la batterie de votre
smartphone donc bon voilà pourquoi pas
une fois de plus quand on vient
l'acheter il faut réfléchir à ces usages
est-ce que vous avez besoin de ça oui ou
non cet iPad pro très honnêtement ça
vaut pas le coup de venir l'acheter tout
seul parce que ça reste une très belle
tablette très pratique mais là où il
devient réellement intéressant et là où
il faut venir l'acheter c'est si vous
achetez le Magic keyboard avec parce que
c'est là où ça transforme votre iPad on
a petit ordinateur je dis bien petite
ordinateur parce que si on vient pas
remplacer un ordinateur c'est-à-dire que
vous avez une vraie expérience de frappe
avec le Magic keyboard avec le clavier
qui est très bien alors je préfère quand
même moi venir travailler taper sur un
Mac je n'ai pas réellement pris
l'habitude de travailler sur une
tablette vous voyez aussi une bonne soit
elle aussi qualitative soit elle c'est
pas mon dada alors je sais pas si c'est
une fois plus moi et mon usage je suis
toujours mon Mac avec moi mais ma
tablette c'est voyagé j'arrive pas à
remplacer le truc alors il y a plein
d'usages plein de choses que je vais
faire avec mais ça je le fais pas sauf
que et je trouve ça très pratique parce
que ce Magic keyboard effectivement
quand on fait de la recherche on
travaille on tape directement dessus on
peut le faire ça j'utilise alors ce que
je vais dire cherche si je mets ça je
fais des trucs j'utilise le Magic
keboard il me sert beaucoup énormément
en mode chevalet pour venir caler
lorsque je regarde du contenu ça je vous
l'ai dit aussi lorsque je fais de la
musique je vais vous montrer l'usage
dans quelques instants avec ludique ça
c'est plutôt cool mais je trouve que cet
accessoire là il reste quand même
extrêmement cher et je vais vous parler
une fois de plus de prix dans quelques
instants je vous le dis il est tout de
suite à 429 € à dire qu'on est à 500
balles accessoires ce qui est presque le
prix de l'iPad 10 qui en tout cas le
prix quelque chose près de l'iPad neuf
donc bon juste le clavier ça me paraît
fou et après ça dépend une fois de plus
de vous et de vos usages vous pouvez
utiliser l'Apple pencil de deuxième
génération qui est magnétique et vous
venir charger directement là bon voilà
c'est normal c'est bien moi j'en ai pas
l'usage j'utilise pas de stylet donc bon
rien de neuf ici ce soleil pour moi mais
voilà donc la question c'est est-ce que
vous devez vous venir acheter un IP ça
va dépendre de vous et de vos usages
alors moi je vais vous montrer mes
usages je vous ai expliqué un usage que
j'aime beaucoup que je trouve très cool
et ça c'est vraiment du Apple purement
du Apple je bouge un peu tout ça
c'est-à-dire le fait d'avoir une vraie
communication entre tous vos appareils
regardez moi j'utilise logic sur lequel
je me mets une petite boucle vous voyez
je fais un peu de musique alors je
gratouille attention c'est vraiment
voilà et lorsque je crée sur logic
qu'est-ce que j'aime bien faire j'aime
bien avoir d'un côté mon iPad dans
lequel je vais utiliser logic remote qui
est cette application juste là et cette
application là elle est hyper canon
parce que je vais avoir ma table de
mixage alors table de mixage mais pas
que eh comme on déchire Apple ça ne
s'arrête pas là je vais utiliser
également logic remote sur mon iPhone et
je me connecte à mon mac donc ça c'est
très très cool regardez hop là je viens
de mettre comme ça et là j'ai un petit
clavier alors le truc qui est très très
cool parce qu'en fait je vais travailler
voilà donc je peux venir moi utiliser
ici mon iPhone comme un petit clavier
sur lequel je viens faire un peu de son
vous voyez que je les mets là
bon on se parle vraiment dans toutes
très très cool donc on va se calmer
c'est pas un truc de fou furieux et
j'utilise mon iPad et je vais l'enlever
de là normalement je le laisse dessus
mais je vais l'enlever juste pour vous
le montrer je l'utilise ici comme table
de mixage donc en fait sur mon mac ce
que je viens faire et bien je viens
mettre en place mes différentes
séquences je colle je découpe essayer ça
là je peux venir mixer en direct et là
je peux venir jouer directement sur mon
iphone donc tout fonctionne ensemble et
le truc qui est vraiment très très cool
c'est que je peux changer de vue ici et
si je veux venir jouer directement je
peux venir jouer directement et j'ai
plus de contrôle ici donc après
il y a plein de possibilités et je
trouve ça très très cool une fois de
plus j'accès à tous mes paramètres et
voyez je peux venir changer je mets bon
d'accord
[Musique]
je vais avoir mes livelue bref je vous
passe un peu le truc alors je tâtonne je
suis pas voilà mais je trouve ça trop
cool pour la création donc pour moi
l'iPad j'utilise vraiment comme un
accessoire de création et pas comme un
accessoire professionnel et pas comme
accessoire bureautique pour la
bureautique j'ai mon mac pour le montage
j'ai mon mac pour la musique j'ai mon
mac mon iPad et mon iPhone et tout
fonctionne ensemble et c'est ça qui est
intéressant et que c'était écosystème
Apple donc voyez les usages ils peuvent
être mixtes qui dépendent une fois de
plus de vous il dépend de de tout le
monde alors on va regarder le prix parce
que c'est quand même le truc qui est
vraiment décisif ici parce que ça taille
pas de pro il est juste canon
canonissime on s'en doutera mais je
trouve cher mais une fois de plus c'est
pas nouveau on regarde bien le 12,
pouces c'est celui-là alors si vous
regardez qu'en version on se prend le
gris fédéral peu importe vous êtes en
128 à partir de 1469 euros c'est à dire
qu'à quasiment 1500 balles on commence à
pouvoir avoir un iPad pro n'oublions pas
que ça le Magic keboard ça vous coûte
quand même 429 euros donc il faut
rajouter 420 balles pour l'avoir et le
stylet il coûte 129 euros si je dis pas
de bêtises 149 euros excusez-moi donc
vous voyez déjà vous avez quand même un
petit billet à mettre là dessus donc là
en gros vous êtes à 1800 euros à 1900
euros vous un nouvel ensemble sauf le
stylet c'est à presque 2000 balles sur
la base l'entrée l'entrée en 128 Go 256
1006 512 1849 un Téra 2300 et le 2
terrain on a 2800 mais et si donc là je
suis sur la version je pense 128 pour
regarder et la version cellulaire vous
voyez ça augmente c'est à dire que je
suis en cellulaire à partir de 1669 € et
si je veux aller le plus haut ici sur le
2 Tera et ben je monte à 300044 €. donc
ça reste un produit très cher ça reste
un produit je viens d'exception ça sera
pas pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde tu dis pas que je veux une grande
tablette de 12,9 pouces non si on vient
l'acheter c'est qu'on en a réellement le
besoin parce qu'il coûte une petite
blinde maintenant comme on dit
professionnel pour des entreprises ça
sera pas déconnant de venir acheter ça
pour un professionnel qui en a
réellement le besoin une fois de plus la
question si on avait vous réellement le
besoin est-ce que même un iPad pro de
l'année dernière aurait sur le même
c'est-à-dire que vous allez avoir le
même écran les mêmes haut-parleurs vous
allez avoir un Bluetooth inférieur en
5.20 que ça va vraiment changer grand
chose vu le tarif j'en sais rien du wifi
6 ou d'avoir du wifi 6 vous aurez la
puce aimant au lieu de la m2 une fois de
plus je pense pas que vous allez aller
au bout de la m2 vous suffira donc
d'aller l'acheter en reconditionné ça
peut avoir un sens bref moi je suis
convaincu par cet iPad je trouve
vraiment super ça dépend vraiment de vos
usages si ça vous sert à rien pourquoi
pas aller sur ce nouvel iPad là qui est
quand même hyper hyper canon et pas 10
donc je vous ai déjà parlé si on l'iPad
airs aussi très intéressant allez voir
pour savoir quel iPad a acheté est-ce
que je peux vous le recommander bien
évidemment que je peux vous le
recommander il a tout il est bon il est
performant il marche bien la qualité top
c'est une super machine je trouve juste
très cher et avec l'inflation ça fait
mal maintenant ça va dépendre de vous de
votre budget est-ce que vous pouvez vous
le permettre oui non si vous pouvez vous
le permettre si vous en avez réellement
les usages posez-vous vraiment la
question oui l'iPad pro 12,9 pouces de
2022 vaut le coup c'est un sacré coup
mais c'est un beau coup et ça reste une
très belle machine moi j'ai beaucoup de
plaisir à venir l'utiliser je vous ai
montré mes usages notamment voilà à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez dans
les commentaires est-ce que vous
pourriez venir acheter cette pâte pro
alors je vous le dis si vous avez un
iPad pro de 2021 de changer pas garder
le c'est beaucoup d'argent franchement
regardez-le si vous voulez acheter un
iPad que vous en avez jamais eu et que
vous avez besoin de ces usages là sur un
iPad pro sans problème posez-vous une
fois de plus la question de 2021 versus
2022 l'AM1 versus la m2 et voilà
globalement je ne peux que le
recommander voilà mais ça va dépendre de
vous et c'est à vous de me le dire
est-ce qu'il est fait pour vous oui non
pas comment vous marquez ça en bas dans
les commentaires et nous on se retrouve
très bientôt pour continuer à parler de
thug d'Apple et pas que de plein de
choses ça c'est chouette je vous
embrasse à bientôt prenez soin de vous
ciao ciao
[Musique]